[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جم
وفي الوقت الذي يحدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى
فللاسبوع الثاني عشر على توالي ينظم عشرات
الاف الاسرائيليين مظاهرات رفضا لخطه
حكومه بنيامينه بادخال تعديلات على النظام
القضائي وتاتي هذه المظاهرات في تل ابيب
وغيرها من المناطق في ظل حركه رفض سياسيه
واسعه وعصيان داخل الجيش
ومن لاهور نتابع هذه الصور لتجمر شعبي
لحزب انصاص الذي يتزعمه رئيس الحكومه
الباكستانيه المقال عمران خان
ومن مكه المكرمه هذه الصور تصلنا مباشره
لاداء المسلمين مناسك العمره في رحاب شهر
رمضان المبارك
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
اصابه اثنين من جنود الاحتلال باطلاق نار
في حواره جنوبيه نابلس احدهم بجروح خطره
ومع احتجاجات تحتدم على ساحه الاسرائيليه
رافضوا خطه نتنياهو للتعديلات القضائيه من
داخل حكومته وخارجها يحذرون من الانهيار
وزير الدفاع جالنت يرفض دعم نتنياهو ويقول
ان خطه سببت شرخا سيقسم الامن والجيش
ووزير الامن القومي يطالب باقالته
بوتين يعلن نشر عشر طائرات قادره على حمل
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا في خطوه
وصفها بانها لا تنتهك نظام عدم نشر اسلحه
الدمار الشامل ويتهم الغرب بتعطيل مساعي
الوساطه الصينيه عبر الاعلان عن تزويد
اوكرانيا بذخائر تحمل اليورانيوم المنظم
ايران تنفي اتهامات واشنطن لها بقصف قواعد
امريكيه في سوريا وتتوعد بالرد على اي
استهداف لقواتها هناك و واشنطن تؤكد انها
ستتصرف بقوه لحمايه جنودها رغم تشديدها
على عدم السعي للدخول في صراع مع ايران
دائره غضب تتسع في انحاء فرنسا مع استمرار
الاحتجاجات على قانون التقاعد
صدامات بين النشطاء وقوات الامن رفضا
لمشروع للري غربي البلاد وزير الداخليه
يطالب القوى السياسيه بتحمل مسؤوليتها اذا
ام وسطه بعنف المتظاهرين واضراب عمال
النظافه يغرق المدن الكبرى بالنفايات
في لقاءنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا قانونا انتخابات المحافظات
في العراق اذ لا يزال الجدل قائما حول
القانون الذي اقره مجلس النواب جزئيا فجر
الاثنين الماضي وفق نظام الدائره الواحده
معتمدا ما يعرف باليه والتي تعتمد التمثيل
النسبي وتقسيم اصوات التحالفات على نسبه
واحد فاصل تسعه لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
ما الذي يحمله اقرار قانون انتخابات
المحافظات من جديد للساحه السياسيه
49% قالوا ان القانون سيعيد انتاج حاله
الانقسام فيما راى 30% ان القانون سيؤدي
لعوده الاحتجاج الى الشارع بينما صوت 21%
على ان القانون سيعطي تمثيلا سياسيا افضل
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا على
المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
قتلى وجرح جرى اعصار في ولايه ميسيسيبي
الامريكيه ومخاوف من ارتفاع حصيله الضحايا
[موسيقى]
اعلنا الجيش الاسرائيلي اصابه اثنين من
جنوده بجروح في هجوم مسلح وقع في بلده
حوار جنوبي مدينه نابلس بالضفه الغربيه
وافادت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان احد
الجنود حالته خطيره واضافت ان مسلحين اطلق
النار على قوه مشاه اسرائيليه من سياره
مسرعه واصاب اثنين منهم خلال الهجوم وقال
شهود عيان ان جيش الاحتلال اغلق بعض
المداخل والمخارج لمدينه نابلس في حين دعا
وزير الامن القومي الى انعقاد المجلس
الامني المصغر
هذا هو اعلنت كتائب وابو علي مصطفى الجناح
العسكري للجبه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين
مسؤوليتها عن عمليه حواره في ردود الفعل
قالت حركه حماسنا عمليه اطلاق النار في
بلده حواره جنوب نابلس تاتي في اطار الرد
على جرائم الاحتلال والتي كان اخرها
اغتيال قائد كتيبه طولكرم امير ابو خديجه
واكد المتحدث باسم حركه حماس عبد اللطيف
القنوع ان عمليات المقاومه في الضفه
ستتصاعد ردا على سلوك حكومه الاحتلال
المتطرفه من جانبها باركت لجانو المقاومه
الشعبيه عمليه حواره واعتبرتها الرد
الامثل على جرائم الاحتلال والمخططات
والمؤتمرات الامنيه المعاديه للقضيه
الفلسطينيه وحقوق الشعب الفلسطيني وقالت
الجبهه الديمقراطيه ان عمليه حواره تؤكد
ان الشعب الفلسطيني حسم خياراته في
المقاومه القادره على انهاء الاحتلال
بعيدا عن التفاهمات الامنيه التي تشكل
غطاء سياسيا على جرائم الاحتلال هذا في
حين اعتبرت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي ان عمليه
حوار تثبت مجددا قدره المقاومه على مباغته
العدو والاستخفاف بامنه وجيشه
وقعت مواجهتهم بين عشرات الاف
الاسرائيليين وقوات الامن على خلفيه
مظاهرات في عده مدن للاحتجاج على مضي
حكومه نتنياهو في مشروع التعديلات
القضائيه التي تصفه المعارضه بالانقلاب
على النظام القضائي وتحييد المحكمه العليا
في تل ابيب رفع المتظاهرون شعارات مناهضه
لنتنياهو والمتحالفين معه من اليمين
المتطرف ويسعى المتظاهرون لابقاء الضغوط
على الائتلاف الحكومي بغيت دفعه للعدول عن
تمرير التشريعات وقد اتسعت رقعه رفض
الخدمه في التدريبات العسكريه من قبل ضباط
وجنود الاحتياط وشملت الاطباء العسكريين
والطياريين وضباط الاستخبارات العسكريه
في هذه الاثناء قال وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي واثقلاند انه يرفض دعم نتنياهو
وقال انما وصفه بشقاق الداخليه العميق
بشان التعديلات القضائيه يعد خطرا دائما
على امن البلاد من شانه تقسيم الامن
والجيش وطلب جلنت في مؤتمر صحفي بوقف
التعديلات القضائيه الى ما بعد عيد الفصح
اليهودي معتبرا ان اسرائيل تواجه تحديات
امنيه غير مسبوقه
في المقابل طالب وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيليه ماربير رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو باقاله وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي افجالنت وعلل طلبه
بالقول انجلنت استسلم تحت ضغط الاعلان
ومطالبات المحتاجين وتهديداتهم الذين
يستخدمون الجيش كاداه للمساومه واضاف
بنيفير ان وزير الدفاع انتخب باصوات
الناخدين اليمينيين وهو في الحقيقه يروج
لاجنده اليساريين حسب تعبيره
واشاد وزير بل زعيم المعارضه في اسرائيل
اشد بموقف وزير الدفاع يؤدي معتبرا انه
قام بخطوه مهمه وشجاعه من اجل امن دوله
اسرائيل
في تغريده على حسابه الحكومه بوقف كل شيء
وعدم تمرير التعديلات والدخول في مفاوضات
بشانها
للمتابعه معنا من حيفا امير مخول الكاتب
والباحثه المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي
والبدايه معك سيد امير فيما يتعلق بعمليه
حواره كيف تفهم هذه العمليه في منطقه تشهد
كثافه في الانتشار العسكري وحاله تاهب
قصوى لجيش الاحتلال
كما يعبر يعني التخوفات والقلاق التي يمر
بها الجيش مؤخرا وتحول الى اشبه بجيشين
يعملان في الضفه الغربيه الجيش الرسمي
الاحتلالي وجيش الاقرب الى المستوطنين
من انصار الدينيه لكن
تقرا اسرائيليا على انها تاكيد على ما على
شرخ القائم بين الحكومه من جهه والقياده
السياسيه وبين المؤسسه الامنيه المؤسسه
الامنيه عمليا فقدت
القدره على القيام بدورها وهذا نتيجه ايضا
تملم في داخل الجيش نتيجه تحضيرات الجيش
بانه اول ما يعني يتضرر منها حاله الرضع
الاسرائيليه التي تعتبر يعني اساسا
استراتيجيا في سياسات الدوله وايضا حاله
يعني الاستخبارات
[موسيقى]
يعني اعلان كانت تصريح اليوم واستغياب
نتنياهو في لندن بعد ان منعه نتنياه قبل
يومين من اداء بتصريحه وتاكيد على نزع ثقه
من قبل
من صقور وليس من
الجناح الليبرالي ولا يوجد جناح النيبرالي
اصلا في الكود لكن هذا تاكيد انه يعني
بالنسبه للتنياهو اشبه بهزه ارضيه في اخر
قلاعه عمليا نتنياهو كان مستعد يعني جاهز
انه يواجه كل يعني الحملات والمظاهرات ما
دام والضغط الدولي ما دام بيته الداخلي في
الكود على متماسك الان بدانا نرى ان
نتنياهو قد يفقد الاغلبيه في الكنيست من
خلال التمرد عدد من اعضاء الكنيسه الجديين
جدا وزير الامين وزراء اخرين
بيتان وغيره اللي لهم شعبيه عاليه جدا
وايضا يرون ان نتنياهو قد في سياسته قد
اصبح عبئا على المؤسسه الامنيه وهذا تحول
مهم ونقراه لانه قد يؤدي الى عزل نتنياهو
في داخل حزبه وهو اللي يعني
ولكن يبقى السؤال نعم يبقى السؤال المطروح
هل يمكن ان تصمد هذه الحكومه الى حين
الانتهاء من التعديلات في النظام القضائي
بحيث يصبح امرا واقعا
ليس بالضروره ليس بالضروره ان تستطيع
تمرير التشريعات القضائيه
من هذا المنطلق اصلا حاولت بشكل كبير
للاسراء بشكل يعني جنوني بالتشريعات في
الاسابيع الاخيره ولم تنجز ذلك من خلال
الادراك انه ما لم ما لا ينجز في هذه
الدوره لن يكون ممكن انجازه فيما بعد
الضغوطات الامنيه الضغوطات السياسيه
الضغوطات الدوليه الضغوطات حتى العربيه
يعني حتى من الدول المطبعه مع اسرائيل
اصبحت يعني يخسر كل اوراقه يحصل اوراقه
الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه يحصل اوراق
الاستراتيجيه الدوليا واصبح مندودا عالميا
الى حد كبير هذا لا يعني ان هذا موقف من
اسرائيل وانما موقف من نتنياهو وحكومته
التي باتت اضعف من اي فتره سابقه
استراتيجيا كما يبدو بدايه عبء على
المؤسسه الامنيه وعلى حزبه الى حد ما لانه
ورثته لا يريد ون ان يرثوا منه حزبا مدمرا
شكرا جزيلا لك الكاتب والختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي من حيث امير مخون
[موسيقى]
الى روسيا وتصريح للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين الرئيس بوتين قال ان بلاده نشرت في
بيلاروسيا 10 طائرات قادره على حمل اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه وبناء منشاه تخزين نوويه في
الاول من يوليو المقبل وقال بوتين ان سبب
هذه الخطوه هو بيان بريطانيا بشان امداد
اوكرانيا بذخيره اليورانيوم المنضب واصفا
البيان بمحاوله غربيه لتعطيل مساعي
الوساطه الصينيه واشار الرئيس الروسي لان
ذخائر اليورانيوم المنظم التي سيرسلها
الغرب الى كييف لا تعتبر من اسلحه الدمار
الشامل لكنها تخلق بطريقه ما غبارا مشعا
وبالتالي فهي خطيره جدا ولابد من ان يدرك
الجميع ان الذخائر التي تضم اليورانيوم
المنظم ستلوث الاراضي الزراعيه في
اوكرانيا كما قال بوتين
لا غريبه في الامر فالولايات المتحده تفعل
ذلك فقد نشرت اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه منذ مده
طويله في اوروبا على اراضي ست دول من
حلفائها في النيتو سنفعل الشيء ذاته من
دون انتهاك التزاماتنا الدوليه في اطار
معاهده منع انتشار الاسلحه النوويه لقد
ساعدنا زملائنا في بيلاروسيا وجهزنا 10
طائرات حربيه بيلاروسيه لاستخدام مثل هذا
النوع من الاسلحه
ينضم الينا من موسكو
[موسيقى]
الخبير العسكريه والاستراتيجي ومن
اوكسفورد فرانك
جاء المحاضر في الاستراتيجيات العسكريه
بجامعه بورتسماوث والضابط السابق في
المخابرات العسكريه البريطانيه ادى معك
سيد فيلجا نور
كلام بوتين هل يعني انه سيتم الرد على
استخدام اليورانيوم او بالاحرى الذخائر
المزوده باليورانيوم منظف سيتم الرد عليها
باسلحه تكتيكيه نوويه
المانيا ليس مرتبطاني بشكل مباشر الرئيس
بوتين قال ان روسيا لا ترغب
بنشر الاسلحه
التي
ترغب بارسال هذه
الاسلحه المدرعه التي تستخدم اليورانيوم
المنظم والتي ايضا او المداخاء وان روسيا
بامكانها بالمقابل ان تقوم بنشر في اراضي
المعركه اسلحه مشابهه
الانتشار المحتمل للطائرات في بيلاروسيا
هي هو امر منفصل وقد يحدث مستقبلا ايضا
لكن انه لن يحصل حالا وفي الوقت الحالي
كما قلت ولكن كما واضح ان الرئيس بوتين
ربط الامرين ببعضهما وقال ان هذا ردا ان
هذا رد على البيان البريطاني يعني الربط
كان كان واضحا بانه سيتم نشر اسلحه
التكتيكيه النوويه في بيلاروسيا
كلا ليس حقا قد كان هنالك الرئيس
البيلاروسي
الطلبه من روسيا ان تقوم بنشر اسلحه
نوويه في بيلاروسيا وروسيا
وافقت على ان تقوم
بتعديل الطائرات القتاليه البيلاروسيه لكي
تكون لها امكانيات نوويه والجيش
بيلاروسيا ايضا لديه صواريخ اسكان والتي
لديها امكانيه نوويه ايضا هذا القرار تم
اتخاذه في وقت سابق قبل ان يكون مساله
استخدام الذخيره
هذه الذخيره التي التي تستخدم اليورانيوم
المنظم بالتالي كانت هذه النقاشات سابقه
بالتالي انظمه النقل كانت موجوده في
بيلاروسيا وايضا سيكون هنالك نوع من
التجديد
[موسيقى]
المخازن التي كانت موجوده من الحقبه
السوفيتيه من اجل ان تتمه وتستخدم لتخزين
هذه الاسلحه وقد ستكون جاهزه
مرتبط بمسره به الرئيس بوتين تحديدا هو
الذي ربط الامرين ببعضهما البعض
بالحديث عن النشر اسلحه نوويه تاتيكيه
روسيه في بيلاروسيا بعد البيان البريطاني
عن تزويد اوكرانيا بذخائر تحوي يورانيوم
منظم الا يدفع الغرب هنا
باتجاه مواجهه نوويه ولو تكتيكيه
مع روسيا
هذه الحق الامراني ليس مرتبطان ربما بوتين
قام فقط بربط هذين الامرين عن طريق ذاته
وجزيره كانت وضعت تقارير ان
يونيو الماضي حول مساله التعديده تعديلات
واعتقد ان هذا الامر جاء حسب طلب الرئيس
البيلاروسي ليس هنالك اي امر مساوي بين
الاسلحه
الذخيره التي تستخدم فيها اليورانيوم
والمنظم التي تهاجم الدبابات وبين الاسلحه
النوويه التكتيكيه التي تستهدف تهدف
تستهدف المدن والمنشات العسكريه ليس هنالك
اي
ربط حقيقي او شبه حقيقي او مقارنه بين
الامرين
اذا لم يكن هناك اي اي رابط او مقارنه بين
لكن الا يخشى هنا ان ترد ايضا وقال الرئيس
بوتين ان لدى بلاده اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه
بالالاف الا يخشى ان ترد بنفس الطريقه
عفوا ذخائر باليورانيوم المنظم
البعض يقولون انه قد تم استخدام هذه
الذخيره
والجيش الروسي استخدم القذائفنكس والتي هي
مشابهه التي ستستخدمها الدبابات
البريطانيه لكنها ليست باي علاقه مرتبطه
بالاسلحه النوويه اعتقد اننا عندما ننظر
الى ما ذكر اليوم وما تم ذكره في يونيو
الماضي تزويدي بيلاروسيا بهذه الامكانيات
وايضا الاعلان ربما
يمثل نوع من تصعيد في الوضع ونرى هذا
الامر يحدث بين وقت لاخر من الرئيس بوتين
عندما يكون هنالك ربما يرغب بتذكيرنا انه
دائما لديه هذا الخيار وهذا ايضا لاغراض
اعلاميه بحته بالتالي لا يجب ان نقلل من
اهميته هذه التطورات اذا ما نظرنا الى
الامر برومته هو خطوه اخرى في
هل هل توافق الراي على ان ما قاله او نوع
تهديد الذي
يعني بادر به الرئيس بوتين انما هو لاهداف
اعلاميه فقط
ان فلاديمير بوتن خلال
ان روسيا تنتج المزيد من القذائف
والدبابات وليديها طائرات هجوميه اكثر مما
يمكن للغرب ان يزوده اوكرانيا بها بالتالي
يتحدث عن امتلاك روسيا المزيد من
الامكانيات بالتالي هي قادره على ان تحقق
النصر في هذا الصراع
ان الاعلان من انه قد يكون هنالك مستقبلا
احتماليه لانتشار الاسلحه النوويه في
بيلاروسيا ايضا هو اعلان سياسي في المقام
الاول لانه عسكريا لا يضيف الكثير لان
روسيا لديها
لديها اسلحه اكثر من بلا روسيا ولديها
ايضا هي اسلحه تكتيكيه نوويه ولديها انظمه
الايصال بالتالي الاعلان برمته على ان بلا
روسيا هي تحت مظله روسيا وانها سيتم
الدفاع عنها بالاسلحه النوويه كملاذ اخير
وايضا لتذكير الغرب بانه دائما هنالك خطر
المواجهه النوويه من اجل اجباري الغربي
واوكرانيا على ان يسعوا الى الحل التفاوضي
شكرا لك مقاومه الاوكرانيه لا جدوى منها
شكرا لك
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من موسكو
وشكرا ايضا
لضيفنا فرانك ليدويتش من اوكسفورد المحاضر
في الاستراتيجيات العسكريه لجامعه بوتس
ماوس
في الوقت الذي تراوح فيه المعارك في
اوكرانيا مكانها تحاول عده اطراف احياء
الجهود الدبلوماسيه فقد ذكرت الرئاسه
التركيه ان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان اكد
لبوتين في محادثه هاتفيه انه يولي اهميه
لانهاء النزاعات بين روسيا واوكرانيا من
خلال المفاوضات في اقرب وقت ممكن اما
الرئيس الاوكراني
فقال انه لم يتلقى اي عرض من الصين
للوساطه والحوار او للقاء الزعيم الصيني
بعد ثمانيه اشهر من المواجهات الدمويه في
ضخمه لم يحسم اي طرف المعركه معركه بخم
تذكر بان حرب اوكرانيا تحولت الى حرب
استنزاف امام هذا الوضع ومع اقتناع الروس
والاوكرانيين تدريجيا ان الحسم العسكريه
بعيد المنال وباهضوا تم تتحرك الوساطات في
السر والعلن للبحث عن مخرج دبلوماسي
الرئاسه التركيه قالت ان الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان اكد لبوتين في محادثه هاتفيه انه
يولي اهميه لانهاء نزاعات بين روسيا
واوكرانيا من خلال المفاوضات في اقرب وقت
ممكن واضاف البيان ان اردوغان شكر بوتين
على موقفه الايجابي تجاه تمديد مبادره
حبوب البحر الاسود واذا كانت قنواته
الاتصال بين تركيا وطرفي النزاع مفتوحه
رغم عدم تقديم مبادره وساطه واضحه المعالم
الصين قدمت هذه المبادره لكن قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه حتى الان مع طرف واحد هو
روسيا ارايت الاوكرانيه قال انه لم يتلقى
من الصين الوساطه والحوار او للقاء الزعيم
الصيني واكد انه بعث برسائل مباشره عبر
القنوات الدبلوماسيه تفيد برغبته في
التحدث مع الرئيس الصيني واعرب زيلينسكي
عن شكوكه في خطه السلام الصينيه قائلا ان
احترام السياده والسلامه الاقليميه يجب ان
ياتي اولا اذا الرئيس الاوكراني منفتح على
المبادره الصينيه وان بتحفظ ويبدو ان هناك
تشجيعا اوروبيا لهذا التوجه اذ قال
المستشار الالماني انه يتوقع ان تجري
الصين محادثات مع اوكرانيا واضاف انه لا
ينبغي التحدث مع الرئيس الروسي فحسب بل مع
الرئيس الاوكراني ايضا لكن الامريكيين في
قدره الصين على الوساطه الخميس الماضي قال
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
واشنطن لا ترى الصين وسيطا محايدا بين
كييف وموسكو واضاف ان الصين لم تدم حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا
كان كيربي يعلق على زياره الرئيس الصيني
الاخيره لموسكو التي اظهرت مستوى التقارب
الذي وصلته علاقات الصين وروسيا ترى
واشنطن ان الصين منحازه لروسيا وان
مبادرتها غير قابله للتطبيق اهم ما تضمنته
هذه المبادره الابتعاد عن عقليه الحرب
البارده ما يعني في الخطاب الصيني انهاء
هيمنه امريكا وتدخلها في شؤون الدول كما
تؤكد المبادره احترام استقلال الدول
وسيادتها ووحدتها الترابيه وهنا تصطدم
المبادره الصينيه برغبه روسيا في ضم اراضي
تعتبر وفق القانون الدولي جزءا مما يشكل
الوحده الترابيه لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الى سوريا حيث تتوالى الهجمات على نقاط
تمركز القوات الامريكيه وقد قبلت برد
امريكي استهدف مواقع عسكريه تابعه لايران
في خضم هذا التصعيد قلن متحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي الايراني كيوان خسراوي ان
بلاده سترد على اي هجوم تتعرض له القواعد
التي انشات في سوريا بناء على طلب الحكومه
للتعامل مع الارهاب وتنظيم الدوله نافيا
ما قال انها اتهامات توجهها بلاده او
تواجهها واشنطن لبلاده بالوقوف وراء
الهجوم على القواعد الامريكيه في سوريا
وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قد قال ان
واشنطن لا تسعى لصراع مع ايران لكنه شدد
على ان الولايات المتحده ستحمي قواتها في
سوريا
لليوم الثاني على التوالي تكون القوات
الامريكيه المتمركزه في شمال السوري عرضه
لهجوم تقول واشنطن ان مصدره ايران
وحلفائها فقد اكد مسؤول عسكري امريكي
للجزيره تعرض القوات الامريكيه لهجومين
منفصلين بالصواريخ والمسيرات الانتحاريه
مساريح الحدث كانت قاعده كونوكو في دير
الزور التابعه لقوات التحالف وفيها اصيب
جندي امريكي وقاعده جرين فيليج في شرق
سوريا التي هجمت بثلاث مسيرات انتحاريه
تمكنت الدفاعات الجويه الامريكيه من اسقاط
اثنتين منها فيما اصابت الثالثه هدفها
والحقت اضرارا باحد المباني دون اصابات
هجمات ليله الجمعه اتت بعد ساعات من وعيد
امريكي على لسان الرئيس بايدن الذي اعطى
من اوتوا تعليماته برد سريع على الهجمات
الجانب الايراني نفى مسؤوليته عن هذا
الاستهداف واكد ان وجود قواته في سوريا
بتنسيق مع النظام ويهدف الى قتال التنظيم
الدوله
من مغبه مهاجمه قواته وبالغايه نفسها اي
محاربه تنظيم الدوله تبرر الولايات
المتحده وجودها في سوريا مع التاكيد على
عدم السعي لاي مواجهه عسكريه مع ايران لكن
في المقابل تؤكد واشنطن انها ستحمي قواتها
في سوريا هذه القوات التي لا يقل عددها عن
900 جندي اضافه الى عدد غير محدد من
المتعاقدين وعدد محدود من القوات الخاصه
وتتمركز في قواعد ابرزها قاعده التنفع عند
مثلث الحدود الاردنيه العراقيه السوريه
وقاعده حقل العمر النفطي في دير الزور
وقاعده الرميلان في الحسكه اما المجموعات
المواليه لايران فيصعب حصرها لكن ابرزها
يوجد في محيط العاصمه دمشق ومطارها ومناطق
في ريفها بالاضافه الى تواجد في حلب ومطار
النيره في المدينه فضلا عن تمركزات في حمص
وفي مواقع عده قرب الحدود مع العراق
للاشراف على خطوط الامداد العسكريه عبر
معابر الرسميه وغير الرسميه
بعيد عن هذه القوات تتخذ القوات الروسيه
من الساحل السوري معقلا لها وبالضبط في
القاعده البحريه في اللاذقيه والجويه في
حميميم لكن حركه الطيران الروسي في سوريا
مقرقه للولايات المتحده حيث اكد قائد
عسكري امريكي قبل الهجمات الاخيره بيوم
واحد ان طائرات عسكريه روسيه حلقت فوق
قاعده التنف جنوبيه سوريا 24 مره خلال شهر
مارس اذار الجاري مضيفا ان التحليقه
الروسي ينتهك الاتفاق الموقعه قبل اربع
سنوات لمنع وقوع حوادث جويه وهو ما يهدد
بالتصعيد الوضع حسب المسؤول الامريكي
[موسيقى]
انضم الينا من طهران نادي الدبلوماسي
الايراني السابق ومن واشنطن الدكتور سينا
الزودي الباحث في المجلس الاطلسي المتخصص
في العلاقات الامريكيه الايرانيه ادى معك
السيد هادي افقهي ايران تنفي ان تكون قد
استهدفت اي قاعده امريكيه ولكن
الا تتحمل ايران مسؤوليه ما تقوم به القوى
المواليه لها في سوريا وهي اصلا من رفعت
شعار اخراج القوات الامريكيه من المنطقه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
احاكي استاذ حسن
والمشاهدين الاعزاء وكل عام وانتم بخير
في الحقيقه هناك احتلال امريكي واضح
ويتجاوز حدود الاحتلال العسكري من خلال
هيمنته على مزارع كبيره للقمح والتي تعتبر
الخزان الغذائي لسوريا وما عدا سوريا
وكذلك تاسيس ميليشيات باسم قوات قد قسد كي
تدافع عن مصالح امريكا الى جانب القوات
الامريكيه وكذلك نقل قيادات من داعش من
داخل الاراضي السوريه هنا وهناك او في
العمق العراقي وكل يوم نسمع بهذه العمليات
التي يقوم بها داعش وهناك افلام موثقه
ومصوره
القانون الدولي استاذ حسن يسمح لاي دوله
يعني تغزى اراضيها ان تدافع عن نفسها باي
شكل من الاشكال التي يمكنها من دحر واخراج
القوات الامريكيه فهناك جيش عربي سوري
وهناك مقاومه الى جانب الجيش العربي
السوري الذي هو منع تقسيم سوريا وتجزء
سوريا واسقاط حتى نكون حتى نكون اكثر دقه
حتى نكون اكثر دقه هناك ايضا في المقابل
قوات
انشاتها ايران تعتمر بامر ايران في سوريا
وهذه القوات تقول الولايات المتحده انها
هي من قامت بقصف هذه القواعد الامريكيه
الان لا نتحدث لا عن جيش سوري ولا نتحدث
عن سوريا نتحدث عن قوات تعتمر بامر ايران
وايران هي التي انشاتها والصراع معها الان
والقوات الامريك يه ما رايك باختصار ارجوك
سيد هادي
باختصار هناك غرفه عمليات روسيه سوريه
ايرانيه وحزب الله وقوات مقاومه كل هذه
الان ضليعه في هذه العمليات ولا يمكن ان
نفصل الجيش العربي السوري من هذه العمليات
لان هناك غرف تتحكم بها في الحقيقه في
القرار النهائي هو الحكومه والدوله
السوريه وليست ايران وايران لم تؤسس لهذه
القوات وانما هو محور مقاومه
الى دقه لنفهم هذه
الهجمات التي
تستهدف القاعده الامريكيه او القواعد
الامريكيه في في سوريا
يعني قرارها ايراني سوري وروسي وحزب الله
كلهم اشتركوا وقرروا قصف هذه القواعد طيب
هنا اود ان اسال ضيفنا ازودي بهذا المجال
ما رايك ان كل هذه القوه مجتمعه تتحمل
المسؤوليه وليست ايران وحدها
اعتقد ان كل الاطراف وكل الدول في سوريا
هي تخدم مصالحها اعتقد ان ايران
قوه هناك لديها مصالح استراتيجيه في سوريا
وفي حمايه نظاميه الاسد روسيا ايضا لديها
مصالح بسبب قواعدتها العسكريه هي تحاول ان
تخدم مصالحها في سلاف نفس الوقت لدينا
الولايات المتحده هي قوه عظمى انا لا
اعتقد ان لديها مصالح استراتيجيه في
البقاء في سوريا
وهذا الاعلان من اننا من اننا هنا لحمايه
صعود تنظيم الدوله هو امر مشكوك فيه اعتقد
ان المشكله الحقيقيه هي ان الربط هذه
الهجمات بايران باعطاء طبيعه الهجمات هو
امر صعب للغايه بالتالي كما قلت ايران
رفضت هذه الالتهاب كان هنالك هجوم على
القاعدات على القواعد الامريكيه من قبل
المسيرات وايضا استخدموها حلفاء ايران ليس
من الموضح تماما اذا ما كانت هذه الهجمات
قد اعطي الامر لها من طهران او لم يتم
اعطاء الامر لها من طهران لكن اعتقد ان
هنالك شيء واضح تماما هو ان ايران مهتمه
بشكل كبير في دفع الولايات المتحده خارجه
سوريا وايضا من المنطقه برمتها بسبب تهديد
المحتمل الذي تراه ايران من وجود القوات
الامريكيه في المنطقه ايران
فيما يتعلق بتعاون ايران مع روسيا اعتقد
انه لا يمكن النظر اليه على انه العين
تحالف استراتيجي بل هو هو
مصلحه سيد ازودي هل يمكن هل يمكن فيما لو
تكررت هذه الى جماد بنفس الشكل على
القاعده الامريكيه هل يمكن للولايات
المتحده ان تقصف او تستهدف قوات ايرانيه
موجوده في سوريا
ان الولايات المتحده ستكون مهتمه بمهاجمه
القوات الايرانيه في سوريا بشكل مباشر كما
ذكر الرئيس بايدن لكن اعتقد انه اذا ما
اصبح من الواضح في حوادث مشابهه ان القوات
الايرانيه كانت منخرطه بشكل مباشر هنالك
فرصه جيده من ان تقوم الولايات المتحده
باستهداف قوات الايرانيه لا اعتقد ان اي
رئيس امريكي بامكانه ان لا يقوم باي شيء
في الوقت الذي تتعرض فيه القوات الامريكيه
في اي مكان في العالم
لهجمات
اخر مره كان فيها مثل هذا الحدث في عام
2019 كان هنالك عده هجمات بين
مهاجمه المصالح الامريكيه من قبل القوات
الايرانيه والتي ادت الى اغتيال الجنرال س
شكرا لك دكتور سينا ازودي الباحث في
المجلس الاطلسي المتخصص في العلاقات
الامريكيه الايرانيه وشكرا
للدبلوماسيه الايرانيه السابق هادي افقهي
كان معنا من طهران
مشاهدينا بعد قليل في فقره المتابعه نسلط
الضوء على اعلان السويد والنرويج
عزمهم على انشاء نظام دفاع جوي موحد
لبلدان شمال الاوروبي ونسال ضيف الحصاد عن
سياقات هذا الاعلان والهدف منه في ظل ما
تعتبر هذه الدول الاربع تهديدا متزايدا من
موسكو مع استمرار حربها على اوكرانيا
الى فرنسا حيث قلت وسائل اعلام محليه ان
16 من رجال الامن وعدد من المتظاهرين
اصيبوا خلال مواجهات في سانسولين جنوب غرب
البلاد احتجاجا على مشروع خزانات مياه في
المنطقه تاتي هذه المنطقه المظاهرات
متزامنه مع احتجاجات اخرى معارضه لقانون
التقاعد الجديد الذي اعتمدته الحكومه
الفرنسيه دون العوده الى البرلمان
لا يبرحونه ففي الشارع دوما يطلق نحنقهم
ما زال غضب الفرنسيين على اداء حكومتهم
يتمدد في الجغرافيا البلد هنا سانسولين
البلده الصغيره في جنوب غربي فرنسا يحتاج
ابنائها من الناشطين على مشروع لبناء
خزانات كبيره في المنطقه
لم يخلوا المشهد من واجهات بين المتظاهرين
وقوى الامن وذكر في الغالب منتهى موجه
الاحتجاجات التي تعم مدن فرنسيه هذه
الايام
ولعل اقواها صدا تلك المطالبه بسحب قانون
التقاعد الجديد المثير للجدل جاء ذلك
ليفاقم امتعاضا شعبيا في فرنسا حركه
ارتفاع التضخم وتدلي الخدمات الاجتماعيه
في تماسك قل نظيره تمضي المعارضه ونقابات
العمل في مواجهه خطط الرئيس ماكرون وحكومه
بورن انه باختصار رفض المساس بالمكاسب
الاجتماعيه للفرنسيين بدا ان نجاه الحكومه
لتوها من تصويت بحجب الثقه في البرلمان قد
زادها اصرارا على تحدي من يعارضون خطط
الاصلاح كذلك هو شان الرئيس الفرنسي
المحذر من الجروح الى العنف والمستعد كما
قال لمناقشه القضايا المتعلقه بالعمل مع
النقابات ولكن دون اعاده النظر في قانون
التقاعد الذي سيراجعه المجلس الدستوري فهو
يريد دخوله حيزه تنفيذ قبل نهايه العام
الجاري حسب ذلك التصلب والاصرار محركا
لاضطرابات لها فواتير اجتماعيه واقتصاديه
وحتى سياسيه
فليس خفيا على السلطات ان حركه الاحتجاج
الجامعه بين المظاهرات
العماليه تعوق السير الحسن لقطاعات خدميه
حيويه الطاقه والطيران والنقل بشتى انواعه
كلها تاثر وتاثر وجه فرنسا مع تمديد اضراب
عمال النظافه مما اغرق المدن الكبرى
بالنفايات حتى نشاط الاليزي بلغه شيء من
اثر احتجاجات الشارع اذ على وقعها تقرر
تاجيل الزياره ملك بريطانيا الى باريس وفي
باريس تكلفه سياسيه اكبر قد تدفع اذا دخلت
السلطات مرحله كسر العظم في ص راعها مع
الشارع من داخل ائتلافه الحاكم تنصح اصوات
عاقله للرئيس ماكرون ببعض الليونه ازاء
مطالب شعبه لكن احدا هناك لا يملك حمله
على واحد من خيارات ثلاثه للتهدئه فاما حل
الحكومه او سحب قانون التقاعد او طرحه على
استفتاء شعبي
وقد طلب وزير الداخليه الفرنسي جيرالد
درمنان القوى السياسيه وبغض النظر عن
موقفها من اصلاح قانون التقاعد بادانه
فيما وصفه بالعنف الشديد ضد شرطه
الجمهوريه واضاف دار في مؤتمر صحفي ان
مطالب المحتجين لا يمكن ان تكون مبررا
للعنفوس اود ان ادعوها جميع المسؤولين
السياسيين والمنتخبين وبغض النظر عن
ارائهم سواء كانوا يؤيدون اصلاح قانون
التقاعد ام لا ادعوهم لادانه هذا العنف
الشديد جدا ضد شرطه الجمهوريه هذا امر غير
مبرر ولا يمكن لاحد السكوت عليه
مدير قسم السياسه والابحاث في معهد
مرحبا بك الى متى سيصمد الرئيس ماكرون
وحكومته امام كل هذه الاحتجاجات التي بدات
تتنوع عناوينها
هذا هو السؤال الذي يطرحه الجميع هنا
اليوم في فرنسا فالغضب يزداد يوما بعد اخر
وحركه التعبئه الاجتماعيه تتزايد
والاضرابات تتزايد وهناك يوم جديد للضربات
يوم الثلاثاء القادم واليوم شاهدت لاعمال
عنف في المحافظات حول موضوع اخر يتعلق
بخزانات الماء والزراعه ولكن كما تعلمون
قد راهن على كسل وتخاذل الفرنسيين
بعد ان كان يتوقع انه بعد تبني هذا
القانون انه سيتراجعون ويسكتون ولكن الذي
حصل هو العكس والضغوط زادت بدل ان تقل
واليوم نجد اننا في الطريق مسدود ولا نرى
كيف يمكن اي باب خروج يمكن باب خروج سياسي
لهذه المشكله لجات حل والتجديد الحوار مع
الشعب الفرنسي اذا لم يكن هناك باب خروج
للحل السياسي اذا الى اين ستت جه الامور
في مكان اخر
انه في وقت ما يتنازل احد الطرفين اما
مكرونه يقرر ان يسحب علق الجزء من مشروعه
ولكن لن تتصور ان رئيس جمهوريه سيفعل ذلك
لان ذلك سيعني اهانه سياسيه الشديد له
يسمح بذلك من ناحيه سياسيه ويمكن ان يكون
هناك في وقت ما ان الحركات الاجتماعيه قد
تتلاشى تدريجيا لكن لا اعتقد ذلك اعتقد
خاصه في باريس ستزداد الامور تدهورا فيما
يتعلق بالتحرك الاجتماعي وايضا ما يتعلق
باللجوء للعنف لانه ليست منظمات النقابيه
هي التي التي تقوم بالعنف بل هناك مجموعه
كبيره من المتطرفين كما شاهدنا اليوم
يستغلون هذا الوضع الاجتماعي
لسائل البلاد والاجابه عن سؤالك اقول لا
يعرف اي شخص كيف يمكن ماكرون الذي هو
معزول وضعيف تمام الان يمكن ان يجد حلا هو
كانه سقط في فخ ولا يخرج منه هذا هو غضب
الفرنسيين طيب ما الذي يضعف اكثر اليوم هل
التراجع عن بعض بنود في هذا القانون او
استمرار التظاهرات واستمرار العنف
لفتره اطول ايهما افضل بالنسبه لماكرون
ليس هناك الا خيارات سيئه بالنسبه
الجمهوريه لا يستطيع سحب قانونه
ومن الواضح انني اعتقد انه بالنسبه له
الحل الوحيد هو ان يقول انه في وقت ما
يقول ان الفرنسيين
تنازله الامر لا يتعلق مباراه بوكر وفيها
خداع كلا هذا امر يتعلق بالنظام والحل
الوحيد هو اذا ما حصل المزيد من العنف فقد
يقود جزء من الفرنسيون جزء الفرنسيين من
توقف عند ذلك سنقف وراء الرئيس الجمهوريه
لقد مبالغه فيما يحصل ولا يمكن نقبل هذا
العنف هذه ما يراهن عليه الرئيس ولا اعتقد
انه سينجح
مدير قسم السياسه والابحاث فيما عداس كنت
معنا من باريس
بمزيد من الاخبار عبر العالم في العراق من
المرتقب بان يصوت مجلس نواب في جلسه على
اقرار قانون الانتخاب لمده ساعتين بسبب
عدم اكتمال النصاب وكان محتاجون تجمعوا
قرب احدى بوابات المنطقه الخضراء وسط
بغداد رفضا لتعديلات مقترحه على القانون
وقد فرضت قوه امتدابير امنيه مشدده في
محيط البرلمان كان البرلمان العراقي قد
ارجع الاثنان الماضي جلسته الى اليوم
السبت لاستكمال التصويت بينما هدد
المتظاهرون بتصعيد احتجاجاتهم واقامه
اعتصام دائم عند احد مداخل المنطقه
الخضراء اذا مضى البرلمان في التصويت
قال مصدرا عسكري يمني محافظه تعز نبيل
شمسان نجا من هجوم شنه الحوثيون والسادف
موكبه في الطريق الرابط بين مدينتي المخا
وتعز اليوم السبت واضاف في بيان ان
الحوثيين شنوا هجوما بالقذائف وان قذيفه
اصابت مقدمه سياره محافظ تعز ما ادى
الاحتراقها قبل ان تتمكن قوه عسكريه من
اخراج المحافظ ومرافقه من السياره بسلام
حسب البيان
من المقرر ان يعقد الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب مساء اليوم اول تجمع انتخابي
في مدينه واكو بولايه تكساس في اطار حملته
للانتخابات الرئاسيه العمل المقبل وتاتي
عوده ترامب الى المهرجانات الانتخابيه في
وقت يواجه فيه تحقيقات في مساعم بدفع
اموال لشراء صمت ومحاولات لالغاء انتخابات
2020 وتحقيقات اخرى بشان وثائق سريه وجدت
في بيته
وكثفت ترانسي الاونه الاخيره من هجماته
على تحقيقات ضده ووصفها بانها ذات دوافع
سياسيه
اعلنت وكاله اداره الطوارئ في ولايه
ميسيسيبي الجنوبيه الولايات المتحده مصر
23 شخصا واصابه العشرات اثر اعصار ضرب
الولايه الليله الماضيه وقالت الوكاله في
سلسله تغريدات على تويتر ان فرق البحث
والانقاذ مستمره في البحث عن اربعه اشخاص
اعتبروا في عداد المفقودين ووفقا لوسائل
اعلام امريكيه فان بلدتي سيلفر سيتي
ورولينج من اكثر المناطق تضررا بالاعصار
الذي اجتاح مناطق شاسعه قبل ان يشق طريقه
نحو ولايه الاباما المجاوره
[موسيقى]
وقع قاده القوات الجويه من السويد
والنرويج وفنلندا ودنمارك خطاب نوايا وذلك
لانشاء نظام دفاع جوي موحد لبلدان الشمال
الاوروبي الهدف هو مواجهه التهديد
المتزايد من روسيا خاصه بعد حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا في فبراير شباط من العمل الماضي
وتعزيز القدره على العمل بشكل مشترك على
اساسي طرق العمل المعروفه في اطار حلف
شمال الاطلسي وفقا لبيانات القوات المسلحه
للدول الاربع النرويج والدنمارك العضوين
في النيتو والسويد وفنلندا اللتين تنتظران
الانضمام للنيتو
وايدتا انضمام اوكرانيا وتشترك الدولتان
في حدود مع روسيا تمتد بنحو
1340 كيلومترا
ترمي بلدان شمال الاوروبي من انشاء هذا
النظام ترمي الى تنفيذ عدد من مجالات
العمل المشترك بينها تحقيق القياده
والسيطره المتكامل الموحده وتخطيط
الاعميين العمليات
وتنفيذها وايضا تبادل الانتساب المرن
لمجمل القوات الجويه في البلدان الاربعه
بجانب توحيد سبل مراقبه المجال الجوي
لمنطقه الشمال الاوروبيه وتطويرها وتبادل
الخبرات من خلال التدريب والتمارين
المشتركه يمكن ان تعزز القوات الجويه
الاسكندنافيه الموحده العلاقات عبر
الاطلسي مع استمرار عمليه التكامل
والتعاون بين البلدان الاربعه
للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
جناز
العقيد الكسندر فوتراتير رئيس تحرير مجله
المجله العسكريه السويسريه مرحبا بك سيد
بوترا
والسؤال عن دلالات هذا الاعلان اهميه هذا
الاعلان على صعيد العسكري وكيف ستكون
علاقته بشكل عام مع الناتو
من عده نواحي لان نعلم ان هذه الدول
الاربعه تتعاون منذ زمن فيما بينها لكن
اعلان بانه سيكون هناك نظام مشترك فيه
حساسات تبعث ببيانات الى عده مواقع سيطره
وقدره
السيطره والصال اوامر الى الدول الاربعه
في انواع هو امر جديد ضمن اطار التعاون
الاوروبي
هو امر جديد واضح ولكن اثره العسكري الى
اي مدى يمكن ان يحقق هدف الدفاع الجوي
هذه الدول الاربعه لديها
قوات متشابهه ونقاط ضعف متشابهه احد هذه
نقاط الضعف على سبيل المثال هو ان اي من
هذه الدول الاربعه في الدول المنطقه
الاسكندنافيه لديها اي شكل لاشكال
صواريخ بعيده المدى المتطوره فلو جمعنا
الاربع دول سويه
فان ميزانيه هذه الدول الاربعه سويه
تمكنهم من شراء الانظمه هذه وضع الهيكل
اللازمه لمثل هذا النظام بطريقه اكثر ذكاء
وبالتالي فقوه الشرائيه
والبعد الاستراتيجي سيكونان امرا كبيرا
وفي يشكل زياده كبيره في القدرات
وامكانيات الدفاعيه عن اوروبا
كيف يمكن ان يكون تعاطي هذا النظام الجوي
الجديد مع حلف الناتو يعني هناك دولتان في
حلف الناتو وهناك دولتان تنتظران
الامر ليس مشكله فكل الدول حتى التي هي
خارج النيتو يمكن ان تشتري وتشتري معدات
ومواد
تقنيه يمكن ان تكون على مستوى المعايير
المطبقه في النيتو وبالتالي القرار هو
يعود النقل البيانات ام لا لكن من حيث
الاساس كل المعدات تعمل في هذه الدول
الاربعه سواء كانوا اعضاء في او غير اعضاء
في النيتو كلها متوافقه مع النيتو
شكرا جزيلا جزيلا لك العقيده الكسندر رئيس
تحرير المجله العسكريه
السويسريه كنت معنا من
[موسيقى]
فيما ننهي حصاد هذه الليله دعوه للحفاظ
على كوكبنا الارض من التلوث والتغير
المناخي لهذا احتفل العالم اليوم بساعه
الارض حيث اطفئت الاضواء لمده ساعه لاكثر
من سبعه الاف مدينه حول العالم في حدث
يتكرر كل عام
شكرا لمتابعتكم مشاهدينا والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]